Welcome back.
We're here with the incredible hair stylist
and my dear friend, Chris Appleton.
(applause)
Who's been giving us a makeover to one of our viewers
all hour long.
And before we get to that big reveal, we wanna check in
with another couple in our audience, Sebastian and Michael.
Hi guys.
Hi.
Hi Drew.
I feel like we've been like catching eyes the whole show.
Absolutely.
I love how you're like leaning in
and your energy.
I've been picking up on it
but what have you guys picked up on from each other?
So we learned fairly early on that we both are into travel
although that's not really been too easy to do lately.
No, but that's a common, that's a commonality.
We like that.
Yep.
Yeah. And then we talked about what we've traveled
for and what we're gonna travel to.
And then that brought us to like, you know
the typical homosexual conversation
topic of female pop stars.
(giggling)
And
And then we noticed that each of our phone lock screens
is our favorite pop stars.
So that was, that was a fun moment.
Yeah.
Who's who?
Kylie Minogue for me.
And Christina Aguilera over here.
I mean
Okay.
Two
This is going well
Gorgeous divas.
Are you guys gonna go out on a date?
We've got skydiving.
What are you guys?
Are you guys gonna do something?
I was thinking maybe we'd go
to Fiji with the other couple for travel.
(giggling)
(applause)
All right.
Well, I think you guys should bond over a cocktail and, and
and we have one for you.
It's called Tea Drops.
They're actually bag less tea blends that are
like a bath bomb of tea that dissolves in your cup.
And they're sending you and our entire audience home
with a hundred dollar Tea Drops gift card.
(applause)
Okay, Chris, you're so excited
because earlier we met Iris.
Uh huh.
And she's looking for a fresh start.
Coming out of a 30 year marriage?
Yep.
Are you guys all ready to see Iris?
(applause)
I am. Alright, Iris come on out.
(upbeat music)
(loud applause)
I can't believe it.
Look at you
How do you feel?
I feel so glamorous.
I feel like I'm dreaming.
Is this me?
I looked in the mirror.
I'm like, who is this girl?
Come on.
Give us a spin.
Give them the full thing there she is.
(laughing)
(applause)
OK. I need my jaw.
Jaw dropping.
I know my jaw. It actually hurts.
I'm like shut, shut this jaw.
And you don't seem like the same person.
No. I agree.
(laughing)
See with the, see, even in that picture
you can see her shoulders the way she's kind
of hunched over more.
And then now how her shoulders go back.
More confident.
That's what a good haircut and a little makeover can do
to you. Makes you feel like you wanna stand up taller.
You know, you feel
like you you're prouder to be in the room.
You know?
How do you feel Iris?
I feel great. I just,
I can't believe this is a total transformation for me.
I didn't expect this at all.
It's like a little bit of a makeover
but this is drastic for me and I feel great.
Chic, sophisticated, glamorous.
So Iris, you are sporting that empowerment boost.
(laughing)
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
(applause)
Your team is great.
Are you open to dating?
Yes.
Are you gonna go on a date?
How are feeling?
Maybe? I don't know. We'll see.
(laughing)
But I love the attitude too, because you know
like we've said, it starts with loving yourself.
It starts with having that relationship with yourself.
Yeah.
I know that from being single and working
on it myself, you know, it takes time to be comfortable
with yourself and doing things for you.
That's a great feeling, cuz then I think when you get
to that point is when you are ready to go out there.
So it is your time now, Iris.
Yes.
To be in a relationship with yourself.
That's what I want.
And when, when you want date here and there
cuz dating is totally fun and should not be off the menu.
(giggling)
You look phenomenal.
Thank you.
(applause)
And you should go into it with complete confidence.
I will.
Iris before we go, we have a surprise for you.
Don't go anywhere.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music playing)